[Musik]
wir sahen in anstieg auf der schießbahn
tauris führen da unser jährliches
verpflichtung für das kader schießen
rosa durch besteht aus zwei
schießübungen eine gefechtsübung
gesamtsieg rund 220 schuss lösen wobei
dazu kommt dass man zwei läufe haben und
für jeden lauf des extremismus und die
korrektur werte des laufs angelis
anschließend werden das heißt wir haben
eigentlich immer mit den hohen zielen
hand und kämpfen uns dann wirklich hoch
sagte lotus 1400 auch quer oder
stattfanden
fahrzeugen gehört
das heißt wenn ich jetzt im fahrzeug bin
schließlich zuerst auf der stelle
und dann natürlich in bewegung die
kanone der laufer hat die nasa ist
stabilisiert
ich brauchte nichts mit richten soll das
geht automatisch brauchen wir auch im
ziel der aufbau und funktioniert auch
ausgezeichnet ab von den vergleich von
dort wieder einmal müssen wir halt dann
auch 1416
schießen
[Musik]